a thousand people used to live in this
block in Northern Syria 800 of them are
now dead Mustafa almawawari spent 22
hours under this Rubble with his wife
and three children he got Rescuers
attention
by banging on the debris
but while mustafa's immediate family
were rescued 20 of his relatives weren't
motherland I have no hope left he says I
sometimes think it would have been
better if I stayed under the rubble
that grief and sense of desperation is
everywhere in Northern Syria where
thousands are struggling and without the
Necessities after the devastating
earthquakes and the decade of War
they've endured before
Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad has
limited foreign aid to the rebel held
North only Sunday were Doctors Without
Borders finally able to enter the
country 13 days after the disaster
the United Nations too has been Limited
in what they can provide we're doing our
best to step up the response as quickly
as we can
but those efforts simply can't meet the
demand as Aid workers have struggled to
keep up with making and providing tents
to the displaced many of those who are
now homeless across Syria and turkey are
still holding out hope family members
can be rescued from under what's left of
their homes and buildings but Sunday
also brought a grim Reality by Nightfall
the active search for survivors is set
to end across most of turkey those not
yet accounted for presumed dead as time
goes on there's no question that the
likelihood of finding survivors becomes
vanishingly small so it's a reasonable
response I think
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
toured the damage over turkey promising
a hundred million dollars in additional
aid for the region when you see the
extent of the damage the number of
buildings the number of Apartments the
number of homes
have been destroyed it's going to take a
massive effort to rebuild Canada has
pledged 20 million so far the funding
will help but for the survivors who've
lost so much the cost of these
earthquakes are incalculable Mackenzie
gray Global News
Ottawa